in 1984 in Compton is where I began my
journey of becoming a tennis player on
beaten down courts I went on the courts
with just a ball and a racket and a hope
and that's all I had I never dreamt of
owning 21 Grand Slam titles I never had
a mum number in my mind I just thought
I'd play tennis and Here I am now
sometimes you you're gonna be your own
cheerleader and you have to be your
biggest in your best Cheerleader I have
a really good team my dad my mom my
coach my sisters they're all so positive
I don't have those types of goals if I
want this number you know I just have
the goal of I want to play well at this
tournament I want to win this tournament
she's an American professional tennis
player who's ranked number one in
women's singles
she's regarded as the greatest female
tennis player of all time she was the
second highest paid female athlete in
2015
earning twenty four point six million
dollars she's Serena Williams and here's
my take on her top ten rules for success
number two is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips in
1984 in Compton is where I began my
journey of becoming a tennis player on
beaten-down courts with my family but as
my side my first goal as Zena said was
to win US Open now what you don't know I
actually my first goal was doing
Wimbledon but what you don't know is I
said I wanted to win at Wimbledon
because Venus said she wanted to win
Wimbledon and then my dad yelled at me
he's like Starla stop copying Venus
because every I copied her way too much
and so I said okay I want to win the US
Open and so that's how that kind of came
about so I truly feel that that day
changed my life and now I had a goal to
begin to worked and I began to work
towards that goal
and I believe that one day I would stand
on that court and hold that winner's
trophy and now I guess thirty years
later I still have goals and I still
have dreams of winning and this award
makes me actually want to work harder to
reach more goals so I don't know if
that's weird or not but I like want to
get off here and just go home and start
training because this is so awesome
that's just me
and she says who's with me growing up I
you know I grew up I wasn't the richest
but I had a rich family and in spirit
and in support and you know standing
here with nineteen championships is
something I never thought would happen
you know just I went on the courts with
just a ball and a racket and a hope and
that's all I had and I it's inspiring
for all you guys out there that want to
do something and want to be the best
that you can be and want to do the best
that you can do you just never give up
because you never know what can happen
you never know who you can inspire and
who you can influence
delicious for willingness
I don't feel pressure I feel like I can
retire today and I wouldn't have any
regrets obviously that's not what I want
to do I never dreamt of owning 21 grand
subtitles I never had a mum number in my
mind I just thought I'd play tennis and
Here I am now and I don't have to I
don't have anything to lose
like everything every single match for
me is like a bonus it's a literal bonus
round and a bonus thing and I think that
approach is able to make me stay calm
and just enjoy you know being in
Australia or being in on these amazing
countries and playing tennis
it's great tennis from gold but it's
Marta reaction to the drop shot from
Abraham's didn't go necessarily for a
can't drop shot but a short slice back
and down line I have to tell each and
every one of you that it doesn't matter
how how old you are how young you are
your age you can achieve anything that
you set your mind to and I always say if
I can do it anyone can do it and the
reason that I always say that because I
didn't grow up with things being handed
to me I had to work hard I had to
dedicate myself and I had to be
determined and I was even outside a
sport it could be education it could be
business it could be anything it
requires discipline and hard work and
determination most importantly it
requires self belief because like me
some people might not believe in you but
you have to believe in you and sometimes
you you're going to be your own
cheerleader and you have to be your
biggest in your best cheerleader so to
all you young athletes take that to
heart and never stop believing in
yourself and really always support who
you are
that's just me how easy is it when you
go practicing now to have what your
mindset is it to improve or is it just
to keep winning or because it's yeah
personally I found it very difficult at
some point ya know for me it's always to
improve and I've had some tough losses
this year but those losses I think were
necessary and they helped me to work on
my game it forced me to see that I need
to get better at this I need to get
better at this and this and now I've
gotten better at it so yeah
but do you ever feel like oh gosh tennis
again that never happens does no and
that's the difference between now and a
couple years ago like ever since I went
through my health issues and my my
really really bad health issues every
moment for me is new and I feel like wow
I'm here I'm playing tennis there was a
time where I never thought I would even
pick up a racquet again let alone play
professionally and then I've been able
to come back and that's what has
injuries injuries affect you emotionally
affect you psychologically maybe even
more than physically don't think they do
and they really can wear you down and
then they become really kind of heavy
almost on your soul on your energy and
so I have a really good team my dad my
mom my coach my sisters they're all so
positive and you know I've been able to
just you just be able to keep that
positiveness around me and so um I don't
know I just feel like I said I just feel
a lot better
how much further can you go that's a
really good question and I don't know
the answer to that I don't have those
types of goals if I want this number you
know I just have the goal of I want to
play well at this term and I want to win
this tournament you know and I don't
want to win this tournament and when I
wake up one morning and I just
absolutely do not want to go on the
court or I have no motivation of going
to court then that's when it'd be good
for me
when I can when I first went into the
tournament I was just thinking how I
wanted to do well and I wanted to go far
and whenever I enter Grand Slam or any
tournament for that matter honestly I
just play one match at a time I don't
get too far ahead I don't think about
the future I just have my mind focus on
that one event and that one match and at
one point and that's how going to every
event
honestly I think sometimes it's innate
mentally like you have to really prepare
yourself you know like I'm just mentally
mentally really tough physically anyone
can do it you can go to the gym you can
work out really hard and you can prepare
yourself and be in the most tip-top best
shape that you can be but mentally I
think personally I think ten is is most
like you know 60% men tool and the rest
is physical so
I always felt like an underdog
it was really small for my age and I was
Venus Williams younger sister I always
felt like I was just fighting to make it
I never felt I would be great one day
training every day for 30 years is
difficult and I also think someone is
out there working really hard and
there's a poster on their wall of me and
they're working to beat me with that I
get out where I go every day I'm sore
but that's the life I chose so there's
obviously days I don't feel like
training but there's no day that goes by
that I feel like losing
sorry valid Vaska a CUDA Kovalenko
thank you guys so much for watching I
meet this beauty because Lucy asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I also love to know which of the
rules have the biggest impact on you and
why what are you going to now changing
your business or your life leave it in
the comments and I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
talking about your own journey as a
black woman having this body the way
it's crafted and constructed appreciated
and not really cure there's not being
what we tend to think of we think of
what's beautiful yeah well I mean that's
a lot of problems that I ran into which
I wrote inside of my book on the line
I ran to a lot of things where people
were like well she's big and you know
I'm thinking well honestly doesn't know
how much weight I lose I'll never be a
size two and at the time I said I'm off
I'm always going to have these giant
boobs in this great big tush but you
know this is just who I am and there's
so many people out there they actually
have my body type as opposed to someone
on the runway and I think it's important
for you to just exhale and what you have
and just be you and just love what you
are and there are times I even say it I
look in the mirror I'm like oh I hate my
legs are too fat or my arms are too this
but you know every it's important for me
to to let everyone know that everyone
has these feelings and everyone has this
moment but you know I also just realize
this is what I am and I love Who I am
and what I am how do you maintain your
desire to keep being at the top all this
time um well that's a really good
question I I thought of different
answers many times and I just think it
just boils down to this is what I do and
I I'm very competitive on the court
playing uno or whatever so I'm just like
I like to do the best that I can and if
not I work hard and I'll figure out a
new way to be the best that I can be in
my potential and honestly I just think
I'm just blessed to be able to be good
at what I do knowing what you know now
what piece of advice would you give to
yourself as you're an eighteen year old
that's always a difficult question for
me to to answer because I think not
knowing what could happen the future
just builds character it builds Who I am
today so the advice I would give to
myself actually I wouldn't say anything
I would just enjoy every moment the
idea and I would continue on